[Musique]
au hit parade des enfants chanteur billy
et le king son rock'n'roll vaut déjà
plus d'un million de 10 à 13 ans billy
est l'une des meilleures ventes en
france
[Applaudissements]
ça dégage ok
[Musique]
il
sémou les filles n ont pas tendance qui
parle comme ça écoute et avec tes fans
comment ça se passe très bien et nous il
nous écrive escompté colis bon il y en a
qui disent bon je vais photo il ya
naïveté ou prou et un truc qui ne
répondent à ce qu'il dit je t'aime ben
je sais pas c'est un truc que je parle à
répondre je sais pas moi je peux pas t
mais j'ai trop petit trop petit ou alors
des fois yanagi écrit qu'ils ont 20 ans
je peux leur dire moi je vais j'ai avec
toi et tes parents qui sont pas déçus de
voir si peu souvent
ben ils sont un peu déçu parce qu'ils
veulent que je m'amuse un peu que
j'aille vrais copains copines tout bon
bah si tu veux qu est ce que vous venez
dans les mains madame qu'est ce que
c'est sandisk de mon fils et comment
bientôt un disque d'or quand on a vendu
500 mille disques cinq cent mille vivent
ils étaient plusieurs fois disque d'or
en trois fois ça représente beaucoup
d'argent douceur ils ont profité un peu
un tout petit peu c'est à dire ça nous a
permis de faire quoi depuis il chante
d'acheter une chaîne déjà pour monfils
et puis quelques bricoles le changer de
maison aussi oui bientôt
et depuis tout a démarré vous êtes
beaucoup plus à l'aise financièrement
oui et puis n'importe comment elle est
obligée de déménager parce que là ça
sonnait tout le temps la porte
il est où chercher des photos est comme
ça comment ils commencent à chanter il
chantait des chansons de d'elvis partie
les écouter parce que mon fils le grand
les écoutais alors lui ça les écoutais
piste mettait à chanter pareil voulu
donner des conseils pour sa carrière
des conseils oui quelques-uns m'enfin si
plutôt son producteur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'en viens au mali
c'est pareil mamie elle tentant pas la
faute du sopi présents jean la scène
producteur de billy que nous sommes ou
là chez moi vous m'expliquez du est née
l'idée de billy ce pas une idée on a dit
à plusieurs reprises que c'était un
petit singe qu'on avait propulsé sur une
scène c'est pas du tout ça
là l'heure actuelle c'est vous qui avez
fabriqué tout son personnage n'en
fabrique pas un personnage on ne
fabrique pas un personnage un personnage
il est authentique où il n'existe pas on
peut fabriquer une maison on peut
fabriquer une voiture ne peut pas
fabriquer un artiste on peut le monde
l'est on ne peut pas le fabriquer
[Musique]
calendrier chargé pour billy la tournée
d'été en 84 a été un véritable marathon
les galas et les télévisions se
succèdent toute l'année c'est la rançon
du succès fini l'école
il prend des cours par correspondance
nous
[Musique]
les médis tard c'est une idée géniale
comment est ce que vous avez monté votre
opération
et c'est une idée qui est devenu qui
citait et qui s'est avérée génial parce
que il ya chaque fois qu'un nouveau
disque qui sort on pense que c'est une
idée géniale et monter notre opération
on n'a pas vraiment monter une autre
opération on a fait venir des enfants
donc voulu avoir des enfants de milieux
différents d'origine différente de
milieux sociaux différents il ya des
papas vrp des papas ou deux mamans qui
ont des des situations plus ou moins
aisés il ya des enfants venus de régions
d'origine ethnique différente
et puis je crois qu'au travers de salle
tous les enfants de france et même
d'europe peuvent se retrouver au sein du
groupe
tout simplement
[Musique]
mini star maxi succès lancée en mars
il réalise le score des 500000 23 mois
plus tard mon amour elle se serait vu
t'as une belle maison
ben moi ça serait d'offrir une voiture à
ma mère et puis après dé vivre avec elle
dans une lignée de l'afrique
moi je vis tout simplement en ayant
beaucoup d'argent d'avoir une grande et
une grande maison avec tout ce qu'il
faut dedans sans que ce soit trop
luxueux et puis avoir une belle boîte de
nuit alors plein d'animaux des chats les
chiens voir tas d'animaux ce que j'aime
beaucoup les animaux alors une petite
une petite baraque en amérique et puis
avec une piscine et porsche et le reste
je l'aide à nos pauvres
la part des enfants par rapport à la
part producteurs représentent à peu près
40% 35 à 40 % donc individuellement cela
fait à peu près 7% par enfant sur la
part producteurs oui c'est ça avec donc
cette année vous avez vendu un million
de disques en gros avec une grosse modo
ils vont le faire ou dépassé oui c'est
ça en top14
donc au bout de huit mois combien
vont-ils toucher c'est comme si je vous
demandais vous combien vous gagnez c'est
un peu un discret mais je vous le dire
je pense que par enfant
va leur revenir grosso modo de l'ordre
de 100 à 150 mille fois plus d'argent
que tes parents
j'en sais rien je suis pas une
calculatrice mais tu es quand même
disque d'or oui qu'est ce qu'ils en
pensent tes parents ta carrière à toi il
s'agit sont ils sont contents mon père
est jaloux parce que les charters ça
fait dix ans qu'ils quichotte des pics
n'y arrive pas sur des enfants tout à
fait normaux je les enfants comme tout
le monde il ya deux matches on doit bien
le match
c'est un peu une école de dressage le
showbiz dressage s'adresse à des animaux
sont des enfants on travaille en
s'amusant d'ailleurs vous verrez que
vous avez vu que ils sont ils sont tout
à fait à leur aise il s'amuse quand ils
travaillent ils travaillent en s'amusant
ça durera les ministères c'est vrai mais
ça durera pas éternellement
c'est dommage sur le côté comme ça mais
toujours les symboles de face et
toujours été bouger tes mains écartées
d'un premier groupe
charlie s'attaque à une carrière solo à
la fois prins et michael jackson son
look la sueur at il le succès de ses
idoles
[Musique]
la pratique du rugby ça commence par les
épices dans la boutique
[Musique]
retrouvant la tête avec les copines en
quoi est il différent des autres groupes
et des autres enfants dit chan il est
différent des autres enfants parce que
c'est tout à fait un autre personnage
bon j'en parlais toujours du loup qu'il
a quelque chose de spécial et c'est
charlie il est très spécial
charlie ça te demande beaucoup de temps
sur une semaine la préparation de télé
ouais ça me demande beaucoup de temps je
vais revendre à gm a aussi souvent à
l'école qu'à vendre monado je viens de
l'île maurice vous êtes apte à dia je
suis toujours si on est tout seul avec
un charlie et ben il n'y a personne pour
l'encourager bon il faut bien que ce
soit moi alors je les encourage beaucoup
non vous comptez sur charlie sa carrière
pour vous aider en sortir oui en face et
dc
si ça marche pour lui bien sûr pour
l'instant il n'est pas avec des délais
qu'est ce que ça vous rapporte
concrètement financièrement pour
l'instant rien tu as envie de devenir
une grosse vedette kobe bryant elvis
bonne carrière comme lui quand il est
mort par ce genre de lui j'ai 25 ans il
ya aussi quatre ans alors ça demande
beaucoup de sacrifices parce que
premièrement je vois pas souvent mon
fils en ce moment et parce que il doit
toujours être à la répétition et il veut
changer beaucoup de failles changer de
look
il faut que je travaille pour que je
puisse acheter des vêtements et les
choses bien mère de famille vous pouvez
rêver vous avez peut-être chez vous vous
futurs stars mais dans le monde des
enfants chanteurs peu sont élus
billy est l'unique chanteur solo disque
d'or un casting de 250 enfants a permis
de sélectionner six mini star charlie
joue la carte du look pour réussir on ne
s'improvise pas vedette
[Musique]